[Music]
the couple leaving right now is honor
and Sharna you know what I've made it so
much further than I ever knew I would
and honestly whether I stayed or went it
was a celebration for me every day I
make it every practice I get through
whatever the case may be I'm going
further than I ever knew away did it do
it hit you in the gut when Lin said he
thinks he's been here for too long
I was definitely taken back that Lin
said that I would think Lin understands
it after 24 seasons of Dancing with the
Stars it's not always just dance it's
that person in their story and their
inspiration and why is it a bad thing
that he's been inspiring people for
eight weeks so good night I didn't come
do this show for those judges what's
next cowboy well I don't know I'm just
riding the wave right now I'm so
thankful for this opportunity and I hope
it leads to many more in the future what
about you mama
I'm actually going on tour with Jason
with the stars we're doing the hot
summer nights tour and it is going to be
epic and amazing I have to tell you last
time I stopped here sympho day he said
to my face I have a huge crush on this
girl he's so hot I mean I have a crush
on her for sure he's so incredibly
talented but he's an amazing amazing guy
listen if I have an exclusive I'll tell
you about it all right of it I love it
you
you